I saw this hilarious as tweet and I have
to share with you guys thank you so this
guy he ended up tweeting out last night
me got any homework Anna nah me what
you're gonna do
Anna have a map I'm working on I've just
found this on her desk and it is a
redrawn map of the United States with
notes attached to it okay yeah that's a
nice drawing New Hampshire and Vermont
have been combined into new hat new
hence month it looks like it should be
combined you see the way it looks no
handsome ah I love this already North
Dakota and South Dakota have been
combined into West Dakota Minnesota
named renamed East Dakota Virginia
renamed East Virginia West Virginia
renamed Virginia Florida lengthened
removing the coastline from several
southern states leading to a second
civil war and Florida's eventual
secession it goes all the way like this
under the whole thing I'll show you guys
again oh wait so there's Virginia and
there's West Virginia right yes but it's
technically north south of each other
it's signed up so Virginia has renamed
to wet East Virginia West Virginia is
renamed Superjail it looks like a
yin-yang actually you should just be
called South Virginia that's funny
pretty much so then the next thing is
Texas and Idaho also lengthened as
decided by unanimous vote that's a whole
four corners replaced with Ohio -
capital moved to Ohio to Chile becomes
lon Chile removing the entire west coast
and causing Chilean American War Chilean
American War is the catalyst of World
War three Wyoming deemed unnecessary and
removed this sounds fun wait America
versus Chile that's not gonna be a long
one whoa and then and then Texas goes
all the way up
Texas has a [ __ ] boner through the
earth what's the thought process behind
like was it just random lines drawn or
they have an actual thought process it
appears to be fantasy
Anna is the sixteen-year-old daughter of
Craig who's an NBC sports reporter so
that's why all of a sudden he's tweeted
this out and it went viral but usually
he tweets about sports yeah yeah yeah
but his 16 year olds came up with this
map and she's a genius creative he ends
up tweeting more in the thread and he
says chill I becomes long chilly
removing the entire with us and causing
Chilean American War was not something I
was really anything folks I realize you
all have a lot of questions
I have many myself we're just gonna have
to wait for her to get home from school
to sort that all this out and then he
says I will note that her disrespect for
Wyoming is notable she has long said as
a rhetoric nun I say that it's a queer
trick
secretary is Wyoming even real and this
has been displayed on the light box in
her room for several what Wyoming when
she has her room and this sounds like
some smart people [ __ ] she's cool but
Wyoming is very real she's funny she's
super funny and he said and he says I
told her that I've been I've been to
Wyoming skied there hung out there for
days it's a real place she responded by
saying uh-huh
and then there's an update a text
conversation between the two of them so
so who do you wanna be she'll be the
girl
okay so then he's the dad says my
Twitter followers have several questions
about about long Chile and other
assorted items from your Matt well it's
Hyrum I think they're they're broader
more existential questions like why and
uh huh they're not asking that about our
current map though are they what a smart
girl he goes whoa that's whoa that's how
to make it whoa
and then the next thing says my
sixteen-year-old daughter just read
pilled us all and then the next one says
update I asked her if Ohio too was a
replica of the actual Ohio or if it's
just a cutout shape laugh my ass off off
off off off
also Ohio too is just the shape cut out
its sole purpose is to
people frustrated I see anyway it's over
14,000 likes now my twitter has been
totally unusable all day I'm glad I
could cause an inconvenience
no sense me stopping now so yeah this
entire thing went viral it was freaking
hilarious everyone is just like this
girl just wants to see the world burn
but yeah that's fun pretty fun it was a
fun like to watch ranch real estate
videos on Wyoming they have like 300
acres for like a couple million dollars
Wow it comes with its own horses and
some of them come with operating ranch
with ranch hands and everything they
live on-site all that you just get you
just have only a million bucks
no not 1 million Oh a couple million
dude that Montana life is what's up son
hell yeah get Affairs in Montana real
estate videos that are really good too I
was born in Billings Montana yeah why
can't say that one of your private
security questions
oh oh you're right oh we know they can't
use that one yeah okay I just wanna use
that one why were you born there so my
dad what no it's okay if you can find
online my dad
randomly went out there for some trip
and he just really liked how quiet and
like beautiful it was so then he started
like going to art school out there and
then from Thailand well from Thailand I
think from Thailand and then he went to
LA and then he went to Montana for a bit
and then brought my mom there for
however long and then I was born and
then like but we left when I was still a
baby to to Long Beach no never I want
you though everyone's like you know it's
so beautiful why did he leave if you
liked it so much they always make the
joke that they weren't expecting my
birth to be a c-section and it was too
expensive so they they say they're
teaching the hospital bill what do they
have like a huge outstanding bill as
soon as I like get scanned with
inflation and everything Oh God okay
never mind is fake sorry guys said you
get a sick house in Montana for nothing
guys I always hear people say you
haven't seen the sky until you've been
to Montana yeah cuz it's like it's the
place where you get like really close to
the atmosphere and it's really really
pretty and there's no there's very
little light pollution well
coincidentally Montana's like right
under where she is from Regina
Saskatchewan in Canada yeah it's like a
dick shape Saskatchewan or Montana
Montana that's not the right one huge
she come by montano yeah California's
cut down because she'll a comes up this
way this is some smart people [ __ ]
though it's been smart dumb people [ __ ]
how is this smart people fit cuz at 16 I
was not thinking about how I could
[ __ ] make the world yeah I'm [ __ ]
smoking weed and have parties dude she
took Texas and just made it look dick
shape yeah Texas before 16 it's always
all pointless though you know I'm saying
it's not like it's pointless
it's very imaginative I'm just glad that
she left Indian alone good for her thank
you that but yeah this is definitely the
product of boredom yeah if anything I
was bored by I wouldn't do [ __ ] that's
what I'm saying it's smart like you have
to be kind of smart to like even want to
tap into this when I was like I watch
cartoons no but I'm saying she's but I
feel like she was sitting in class
during like a three-hour lecture and was
like I'm just gonna trace this map and
then he raced some lines and say this is
what you know you should know what Idaho
is I don't even know if I know what I
don't know was it six there's a lot of
states that I forget exist in the u.s. I
don't know what's going on you know
what's great is that we're like they're
ignorant I don't know what to haven't
even the heart of the u.s. is forgetful
well you know and in the north part in
between Illinois all the way to [ __ ]
Washington what the [ __ ] yeah I mean the
other Washington
this is the part I do Indiana which is
really it's the kind of no it's not only
a dick shaped unfortunately okay so this
is like I also go to Ohio Ohio is here
go to left no no that's not how go to
Chicago North Chicago Chicago is go to
the right
that's Indiana yes LLL annoy and that's
Michigan that's Kentucky Kentucky I
don't know what the [ __ ] these guys are
I think that's Missouri no that's I
don't know what the see just cuz I
recognize that show yeah yeah that one
the drumstick it's Kentucky oh [ __ ]
there's Oklahoma right above - I never
learned that song that tells you all
this D o United States Canada Mexico
Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru
oh that's Romania yeah that's the world
I know are you ready for how weird this
[ __ ] is name a South American country
and I'll tell you the capital of it
Olivia
Chile Bolivia what do you I said Bolivia
I know
why'd you do that Colombia Colombia
Colombia hold on cuz it's a song - okay
okay you're away Montevideo what a loser
I don't remember the song really it's
like a rhyme what about Nicaragua just
[ __ ] Nicaragua not there okay where is
Lake Titicaca located at the Disney
Channel [ __ ] thing really song it's
simply a place though guy yeah Lake
Titicaca right behind Bolivia and Peru
South American country does this
landmark belong to Santee alley excuse
me
Santee alley you haven't heard the wolf
famous Santee alley but just thought the
market was it in a fast and furious
movie yes I feel like they throw a bunch
of those landmarks in there now where
did you learn this rhyme my Spanish
class was one of the only things I
retained you took Spanish yeah it's
pretty smart you know I learn from my
Spanish class freshman year Padre
nuestro que estas en el CA
santificado sea tu nombre being and also
trust to rain no I guess a tu voluntad
that's a fart like what does that mean
that's our Father in Spanish why would
you learn they need a separate church
from stage because they're you taught
you that in schools I went to a Catholic
High School for one year I get it that
let me tell you though when I was trying
to get the Latin ladies back in the day
that was a nice little impressive little
bit like who I want to play with you now
I know that's what sucks about it though
is I'm like no no no South America I
can't do that I can't do America
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]